[Musique]
Twilight c'est le numéro 1 aux
États-Unis c'est des vampires qui vont à
l'école qui aiment faire le sexe ah ou
je veux que la rencontre elle a l'air
naturiste m tu lui as bien coulé le becc
c'est bien je pète les fores arrête de
te monter le ti jackyck pourquoi tu
montes comme ça sur ton grand cheval
hein aujourd'hui rien que pour monter un
petit commerce tuas le choix entre la
peste et le coléra prenez le coléra
patron il y a l'oncle de mon père qui a
eu la peste il est mort comprends-moi la
elle me tient par la couille ta fille
elle m'en veut elle est rancunière comme
une vieille mulle afghane merde tu
crains beaucoup du cul